el tiempo para el título 42 se acaba a
poco más de 24 horas de que caduque la
medida miles de migrantes intentan
cruzar a territorio estadounidense el
hecho genera esperanza y confusión pero
la posición de la Casa Blanca es Clara
permítame ser claro el levantamiento de
la orden de salud pública del título 42
no significa que nuestra frontera esté
abierta de hecho es todo lo contrario el
uso que hacemos de nuestras autoridades
de control de la emigración en virtud
del título octavo del código de Estados
Unidos implica consecuencias más duras
para las personas que cruzan la frontera
ilegalmente
los temores de que hasta 10.000
migrantes por día traten de cruzar la
frontera han dado impulso a los Estados
más conservadores en Texas el gobernador
grega a botín informó que envió a más de
17,000 migrantes a ciudades gobernadas
por demócratas como Nueva York
Washington DC Chicago o Filadelfia el
gobernador de Florida rondés antis
promulgó una ley que entre otros efectos
prohíbe que los inmigrantes en situación
irregular obtengan credenciales de
identidad conduzcan automóviles incluso
con licencias de otros estados y obliga
a las empresas a utilizar el sistema de
eBay un software que comprueba el
estatus migratorio de los trabajadores
nadie tiene derecho a emigrar a este
país ningún extranjero nosotros
determinamos Cómo estadounidenses Qué
tipo de sistema de inmigración beneficia
a nuestro país pero cuando se hace
inmigración no es En beneficio de ellos
como extranjeros es para su beneficio
como estadounidenses
de cara al fin del título 42 heredado de
la era Trump la administración de Joe
biden promulgaría una ley A última hora
del jueves que impediría solicitar asilo
en Estados Unidos a quienes no lo hayan
hecho en los países que previamente
transita